let's go to Brad from California Brad
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
um hello David um I just have just like
one question like now that the GOP guy a
half majority but a more narrow one than
the polls said yes are they gonna try to
initiate any investigations onto
President Biden and his family yes
I mean listen why do you think so
they're telling us we should believe
them when they tell us they're saying we
are going to investigate Hunter Biden
we're going to investigate Joe Biden we
might investigate the 2020 election and
the way we want to investigate it
they've Marjorie Taylor green wants to
impeach Biden although congress former
Congressman Joe Walsh told us he doesn't
think that's going to happen yeah I
they're saying they're going to do it
and I believe them
yeah and you and I just I just want to
ask why do you think they are gonna do
it like just to stole time not to pass
any legislation just to try to stall
Biden in his presidency they are going
to obstruct legislation anyway so why
not do these politically motivated
investigations which maybe will hurt
Biden and Democrats in 24 if they were
to turn something up or if Democrats
react in a way that's bad for them I
mean take a shot and see if maybe it'll
help them in 24 to do these
investigations why not why not try
they've got nothing else
I mean yeah they got like bad
congressmen like they got people like
Mario Taylor green who makes serious
like dumb remarks like the waterfall
wire fi okay sorry I can't speak you can
make an absolute perfect sense Brad
yeah sorry
um I'm like the GOP does have Congress
people congressman
Congress people like Marjorie Taylor
green who yes based on all the all the
remarks I've seen her make over the
years like just like a crazy extremist
absolutely Brad listen how old the guy
are you
I'm 14. 14. wow and you're paying
attention to American politics huh
yep I'm a political guy and a teenager
that's fantastic I'm so so I'm it's an
honor to take your call Brad
yeah I gotta go now all right okay yeah
I don't want to keep you all right um
hope you don't get in trouble for the
call uh from your parents or anything
like that there's Brad 14 years old from
California very very important stuff
let's go next to Sam from Minnesota Sam
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today
uh hi I'm remembering when you talked
about latinx a little while ago yes
um I mean I never understood why people
say
it that way Latin X instead of like
Latino Latina latinx like Kleenex
um I I wouldn't use it myself but if I
did I would use it yeah the
pronunciation is the least of my
concerns with it I'll tell you that
right exactly exactly
um I want to hear your opinion as a
Latino about what I think is
realistically the alternative to that
like the English language doesn't have a
lot of gender terms and some of the ones
it does are going away like actor
actress are just it's just actor now for
a lot of people yeah so I think the most
likely outcome is that it's it's Latino
there is no Latina everything's Latino
so if I'm right what do you think of
that and second do you think I'm right
or wrong so I I'm gonna opt out of the
prediction part we're just humans are
terrible at making predictions what do I
know maybe your idea is if I understand
it correctly is as follows instead of
adding a degendering third word instead
of Latino for male and Latina for female
email latinx or latinx okay you're
saying Latino is used by everyone so
it's simply no longer denotes gender hi
I'm a Latino woman I'm a latino man it's
all Latino that's that's the idea of you
okay uh I have absolutely no idea
whether that will happen and I have no
interest whatsoever in making it happen
but what I will say is the following it
should come from the community it
shouldn't be imposed by mostly
non-latino Americans because it's right
or better right it should come from the
ground up if Spanish speakers
all over the Spanish-speaking World
decide we want to do that
then sure do it but for me it's working
fine the way it is right now
oh yeah I don't know if it'll happen in
Spanish I just think it'll happen that
way in English
oh in English oh yeah yeah so so Spanish
can do whatever it wants but like if
you're talking in English yeah you know
I think that as an English speaker it's
just going to be Latinos everything I
thought it already was that way in
English I never hear anyone in English
say Latina
well I don't know I you know I hear
people speaking English and they'll say
Latino but maybe they're using it in a
Spanish way to for lack of a better word
well I don't know what it is yeah it's
an interesting idea interesting idea
all right very good thank you for the
call
oh they seem to be gone already boy all
sorts of crazy stuff going on today